all right let's move on to the next one
corner what is it the next category is
the most wholesome moment award yeah I
think we've had plenty of holes yeah
yeah I mean I feel like this year just
because we've been traveling so much and
a lot of us have been doing a lot of
stuff off camera that just ended up
being trash stations and ended up being
a lot more wholesome than I guess we're
used to yeah we we thought that's why I
had to do that entire episode really
like you know kind of even it out pull
everyone back down yeah you know a lot
of a lot of trash taste is us arguing
and shouting with each other but you
know at the end of the day we're still
friends people can forget that sometimes
moments this year let's check out the
nominations though yes so we have um
this one is wholesome because we didn't
know we were being recorded we did this
was such a kid can you play this one in
this video this might be my favorite
video it's very awesome
[Music]
foreign
I have such a visceral memory of this
hug it was just like I don't know
because this was like the first song dad
comes back from getting the milk
actually comes back do you know how do
you know how no this is wholesome this
is so wholesome that it didn't get memed
at all yeah people just people just post
the clips without like caption all right
I did it Connor was the first one to me
man but Emily bringing the boys fruit
gifts yeah which was very wholesome
because we didn't know this was
happening this this was tough because uh
we were we brought Emily on to like
destroy her for her food takes and she
comes on and like disarms us and we're
like Emily what the [__] man how can you
do something so wholesome just made it
10 times harder to roast you yeah yeah
exactly smart uh we got bird story as we
mentioned earlier awesome we got Connor
completing the cycle very very wholesome
very very helpful one of the clips I
guess so yeah
I feel like what makes that so wholesome
is that people forget now or people
haven't forgot but it feels like it's
been such a long time since
the World opened up again we got to
travel and people had been stuck in
their homes for two years yeah and just
having Kevin just kind of be like hey
guys I missed you guys helped me through
a bad time and I'm just like [__] man
yeah what up bro and then we got [__]
faced that night yeah we got absolutely
[__] shit-faced uh honestly all of
these could win I'm happy with any of
these winnings
any of them deserve it and they're all
all great memories I think we all share
absolutely but there can only be one let
us know pull some
and the award goes too
Don and Joey hugging
he's very wholesome very wholesome very
wholesome this is this is going to be
one of those videos I'm gonna look back
on in like 30 Years and [__] cry you
know you know what I mean like the good
old days man I felt like watching the
end of an anime yeah yeah it did
it's like they did it they [__] did
it oh hell yeah thank you guys thank you
very much what was the top three though
so your video was 36.5 yeah
two
oh wow wow
oh yeah I mean that was very very
wholesome indeed appreciate it
appreciate it
at the end of the cabin episode yeah
yeah that's yeah all right I'm glad the
Kevin yeah
thank you guys uh now we're going the
opposite direction I wouldn't say the
opposite of wholesome but uh you know uh
we like to talk about a lot of our
problems here on trash days some of them
are genuine problems some of them are
the most [__] first world problems
you could ever imagine uh we're like
you're talking about I don't know I
don't I don't know
yeah
this moment yeah is the most privileged
moment of War there's plenty of those
Greatest Hits yes yes you know we I did
we have this in the first Trash Taste of
water yeah we added it in the second one
we added in the second one so we didn't
know trash teeth would blow up
we just got progressively more
privileged everything what can we say
guys uh we're not relatable anymore you
know
we fell off and this award proves it
because the most privileged moments of
this year were gone having three
weddings okay that's very privileged
that is that is very very privileged uh
when did you do this uh this was in LA
this was because they wouldn't give them
a beer yeah they wouldn't give me a beer
and I had to like literally bring out my
famous birthdays at my Wikipedia page uh
as ID to try and buy a [__] way it's
such a flex it's such a flex I'm not
poor Sydney
all right keep saying that Zuni yes uh
Joey getting Chad and Ludwig into a bar
in Australia oh that was in Sydney yeah
yeah manager recognize me yeah Felix
getting a private jet for his dog that's
very good privilege and Connor's coffee
machine why is my coffee machine on here
I mean because how much did you spend on
that [__] coffee machine it's only
two Grands bruh hey hey it's worth it
now she knows it was two grand that's
not privilege listen this [__] coffee
machine I I even if I've already traded
my firstborn son like eight times
already on this podcast I'm trading them
again for another one I'm bringing him
back and then training him again I I
don't think I've ever spent this much
money on something that also gave me 10
times the amount of Joy back I would
have paid more honestly
it's so goddamn good that machine I love
it but uh out of all of these absolute
privileged moments they can only be one
winner It's gotta be it's got to be the
three-way It's gotta be it's Gotta Be
the three ready It's gotta be it's gotta
be easy it's not I'm gonna cry so
balance out the most wholesome moment
yeah it's gonna be the three wordings
let them know let them know all right
and the winner of the most privileged of
moments of trash taste goes to
Felix getting a private jet for his dog
I think on the grand scale of things
this is probably not I'm I'm gonna I'm
gonna call it right now uh I don't think
this was his most privileged moment well
what was his privilege moment oh yeah I
think that's the most privileged Felix
might you know
private jet for his dog you know his you
know his dog I get that if I was in
Felix's shoes I would do exactly the
same thing you know
um never been to Greg's yeah that was
yeah I'm living in England that was
crazy to me that that I have never heard
privilege in one line until I heard
Felix say that man
yeah like you know getting a private jet
for your dog I understand I agree you
know I've never been to Greg's Felix
what the [__] man what the [__] you were
living in England for how many years
that's crazy imagine having a loving
wife who makes sandwiches for you like
that's just you disgusting
I've been in the UK twice and I've been
to Greece what came second or third
second was God having three weddings
yeah
okay
[Music]
well deserved
moment it's all Great Moments all right
let's move on to the next one which I
think again is just a pinnacle of trash
taste because uh you know trash days is
definitely not a podcast where you come
uh
[Music]
that where you come to hear a bunch of
men talking about very well researched
things yeah so yeah this is the perfect
award for that we don't we don't have
nuanced opinions no of course not we
definitely do our research we just say
[__] so we have the I made it the [__]
up award which just explains itself
really uh so let's uh look at the
nominations aristol events of thinking
that whole episode was a [__] fever
dream did I say this I think you said
that yeah
I love the fact that the thumbnail just
has you with like
well you really thought such a perfect
thumbnail uh we have Hunter getting
canceled yeah this uh I remember this
kind of like blew up on on the Reddit
because I remember we recorded a few
episodes in a row and I think we just
all misread the news and we're like
Hunter Hunter got canceled and it has it
hasn't actually no cancel just on Hiatus
again yeah yeah bro it's never it may as
well be canceled it is never getting
made yeah it is never getting made and I
I believe it's getting moved over or
something I haven't actually read the
news article in a while so I can't
imagine why are they made it over
there's not going to be any [__]
chapters you know what I'm okay I'll be
honest I'm making [__] up as I go along
now I don't actually know what happened
I I kept my mousetrack because I don't
want this moment to be in next year's
Wars I'm just saying [__] I can't
actually remember the news article uh
but uh all I know is that it wasn't
canceled no yeah it may as well be it
might as well be uh 60 hertz monitor is
the same as this is such a dog [__]
that's not even like an eye made of the
[__] up that's just my opinion I think
that is I made it the [__] up because
there is a difference okay I guess so
there is no there is no there isn't it's
the same Michael Reeves boxing coach
telling him he can't nut all right yeah
smell it apparently if you did I don't
know what that means I suppose so I
don't know uh Crystal and Connor he
booked under parich office I guess this
came under them I made it the [__] up he
did make it I mean he made the name the
[__] up yes
between logarithmic and exponential
exponential and I believe we both made
some points that were accurate and some
points that were completely inaccurate
yeah and we were just it was like the
dumbest argument on trash days because
there was two Engineers arguing for
something that they studied in their
degree and neither of them got it got it
completely right that was more right
it means anything yeah uh his name or is
that it okay that's it all right it's
got to be either Aristotle it's got to
be the Aristotle I just love the
Aristotle thing at that entire I
remember this episode that entire
episode
I can also see uh Barry Chopsticks yeah
yeah sure yeah maybe the anime fans will
come through for the Hunter
let's find out shall we the winner of
the biggest I made it the [__] up award
it goes to
Chris telling Connor he booked under
Barry Chopsticks well done he didn't
make it the [__] up damn Barry Sean
sticks with the two doves this year bro
holy [__] what were the breakdowns I'm
curious
okay uh 60 cards modern is the same as
140 Billboards it was 18.2 percent that
was close yard and that little aerosol
very narrowly avoided where a lot I make
up a lot of [__]
everything yeah yeah don't trust me